hi everybody
in the next 30 minutes i have the
pleasure to present you some of my
learnings from many years of experience
in demand forecasting and specific
and time series predictions in general
so after a very brief introduction into
our use case of demand forecasting
the talk will be split in 10 different
concepts
and don't get worried if you get lost in
one of them
they are only loosely coupled so you can
just jump right back into the next one
demand forecasting is very important for
supply chain management
with the most prominent example being
its usage as a forward-looking component
in order optimization on the different
stages of the supply chain
so demand itself is a random variable
and it
comes time tagged so that means this
thing is about time series forecasting
you can see such a time series in the
plot on the left side
so and the different stages of the
supply chain also come with different
flavors of demand
so on the lower end on the retail side
demand usually comes as point of sale
so that means sales is your target
looking at sales data in the past
so this can be from grocery supermarkets
fashion shops also online shops
the typical prediction dimension there
is product location date so the item in
this store on a given day for example
and you have many influencing factors
available like
prices promotions and so on and you
usually see a quite regular demand
pattern
coming from the fact that when looking
at the
the full day you basically not looking
at an individual customer but something
like an average customer behavior
on the other hand if you look higher up
in the in the supply chain
and on the manufacturing side you see
demand usually as orders
so that means a retailer for example
ordering at the
consumer packaged goods company so there
the customer
if it's a big retailer can be important
as a potential additional prediction
dimension
so this is one of the aspects that leads
to
this famous bullwhip effect that
that the uncertainty gets higher the
higher you go up in the supply chain
what is depicted actually in the right
the right picture on this slide so also
you have usually fewer available
influencing factors here
so which makes this a bit tougher to
predict in the end
so one thing to mention is that the
target here can also be a sensor data so
for example
in the case of retail sales data that
can be out of stock situations or
markdown sales
that you actually have to correct for
when you want to do a proper training
so the first thing to mention here is
why we would actually use machine
learning instead
of of a traditional univariate time
series forecasting method
so that you want statistical learning
from a business perspective
is clear because your automation is
crucial here so if you look for example
at a typical retail grocery chain
you have thousands of items hundreds of
stores that you want to predict daily
and you definitely don't want to do this
manually
so but why use machine learning and not
just the univariate time series methods
so the re the first reason is that you
can do a combined learning on all of
these time series
so in in the univariate time series
forecasting you will do an optimization
individually and in
machine learning you can just combine
all of them and by exploiting the
commonalities between
between different attributes or
hierarchies in the data
you could drastically reduce the
variance the other thing
is that with machine learning you have
natural consideration of external
variables
so this can be prices promotions weather
so such things you could just use as
features in machine learning and by
doing so you would drastically reduce
the bias
so in the plot on the on the lower side
lower right side here you see the time
series of one product summed over
over several locations and you see a
weekly pattern basically
and overlaid you see
quite an increase in sales in the blue
period which is actually promotion
so there's a promotion active and this
this would affect uh
would have the effect on the sales that
it goes up dramatically and this you
could use the simply as feature in a
machine learning model for example
that means what you will see in the
following
is that i will use this famous bias
variance tradeoff of statistical
learning
as example in some of those concepts so
here actually it would mean that you get
a reduction both in variance and
in bias if you use machine learning over
over traditional methods
so you should definitely use it
so nowadays all of the bus in machine
learning is actually about deep learning
but uh what i want to to uh to show you
is that you should should not just uh
write
jump onto deep learning and uh and
ignore feature engineering completely
so feature engineering can outperform uh
feature learning dramatically
actually and the reason for this is that
you can
include domain or prior knowledge uh by
doing so
and this beats a pure learning from data
usually so because this is kind of a
combination of
the bottom-up approach of machine
learning from pure data and top-down
models including this prior knowledge
so this can for example come quite handy
if you want to learn
specific potentially rare effects so
the plot the upper plot shows the time
series where you have again a quite
prominent promotions effect
so this is something that you can
basically just include as a
as a pure flag but there can be other
things that that are very important for
example the duration of a promotion
so a promotion might uh might be them
towards the end for example and giving
this a specific
a specific feature can be quite helpful
for the model another example would be
if you think of weather
that is hot in the summer so the pure
temperature as raw data
is not very useful for a method because
this is
uh this is something that happens all
the time but
the first sunny weekend for example can
create such a sales bike for example and
this
uh you would like to have a specific
feature in your in your method
otherwise it is quite difficult for the
for the machine learning algorithm to
find it out by itself
another example that goes a bit further
is
you can also include a sub estimator in
your model for example the price demand
elasticity
so in the lower plot you could see on
the x-axis the relative price
which is basically the reduced price
divided by the normal price of a product
and the demand on the y-axis you see
that the lower the price the higher the
demand
and this uh comes with um with an
exponential form in this case and is
also modeled as exponential
and the slope of of this elasticity
you could actually categorize in uh in
different parameters so you could have a
parameter for each store for example
so this would reflect the fact that uh
maybe in different regions the people
show a different
uh a different price sensitivity
in terms of of their demand so as having
something like this as feature in the
model is
quite helpful and if you go even a bit
further you could also think of
of product attributes that you would
product or hierarchies that you would
learn from images of a fashion web shop
for example or from
from the description of products
so that means in the end i would say you
definitely should not feel ashamed
of featuring a feature engineering it
can help to improve your models a lot
especially in demand forecasting
okay an often underestimated topic in
machine learning methods is
the pre-processing of the features so a
lot can be gained if you uh if you use
statistical methods in a in the clever
way here
so i will show you two examples so the
first one is
the binning or discretization of
continuous features
so what is a good method there is
something that i call your eq statistic
spinning
so this basically means that you arrange
it in a way that you have approximately
the same number of observations in each
bin
so by doing so you can actually remove
outliers which might help to to
stabilize your method a lot
going a bit further um you
can use on top of of spinning uh a
smoothing approach
so this would first of all look at each
pin and consider in each pin the target
mean
so this means a target encoding so in
the in the upper plot
you would see the different eq statistic
bins
for for this for this feature and you
see
the data points as the target means in
each of these bins
and then you could actually fit a spline
or a vertical polynomial or any other
functional form through this data
and going forward you would then not use
the raw data points but use the fitted
data points
so by doing so you would ignore all
these fluctuations that you see in the
plot
which drastically reduce the variance
and could get rid of lots of overfitting
so and this actually comes completely
for free um
another way this is also you could also
think of this as another way to include
prior knowledge
so in the lower plot this is a this is
the time trend
so you see uh data over several years or
with a seasonal
uh with a seasonality uh and also with a
with a trend that's going up over the
years and here the
uh the functional form that you are
fitting is just a straight line so you
basically have just a linear time trend
which you could use also to include this
knowledge i will come to that
later on again so definitely you should
make use of pre-processing
and one more example of the bias
variance tradeoff
is the encoding of categorical features
so
um if you think of demand forecasting
the index of of the samples we are
looking at besides time is products and
locations
and products and locations usually come
as ids so that means
here you have two very important uh
categorical features that you want to
use
to basically uh learn the effect from
individual time series even if you do
the optimization
of all of them together and two
possibilities
to use them as machine learning features
would be
first you just do a separate treatment
of each
category so this is basically what uh
what you see on in the upper plot so
there we have uh
here one one category for each
for each item number and you would see
here again the target mean
uh and everything in in every bin um
and uh doing so basically means that you
need uh the capability of a method to
deal with high cardinality
of such categorical features another
possibility would be
that after the target encoding
you would actually put everything to a
single variable
so that means you use the the target
means in each bin
and just put them in one single variable
which you see in the lower plot
so this can then can also be instead of
the mean
uh to include the trend for example you
could also use an exponential weighted
moving average for this
so of course always looking only in the
past of this productive patient
combination
the two of them are preferable in
different situations
so basically what you see is that
the separate treatment has a higher
variance but a lower bias
so and vice versa for the uh for the
mean
encoding and it depends on the situation
in which you are in
so usually you would say if you have not
much external
information available it is it is safe
to jump on the mean encoding method
because it reduces the
variance and there is not so much to
learn from from the other features
and in retail it is often preferable to
actually use a separate treatment
because you can make use of the
correlations with all other external
features
so in the end it is very important that
you think about it and treat your
categorical features well they are very
important
okay so now we go a bit beyond the pure
machine learning and
look into possible applications for
demand
shaping rather than forecasting so that
means
i mentioned before that uh statistical
learning and machine learning is just
curve fitting in many dimensions
uh if you really want to tell something
about the causal structure in your data
you need for an add-on to machine
learning so machine learning and data
are not enough
to describe the causal structure and
such an add-on is usually a causal
assumption
so what we end what we want in the end
is we want a method that allows us
to predict something that is called
counterfactuals
which is the fundamental problem of
causal inference
which asks what could have happened
instead so what
what is the issue is that you are we has
usually only one
uh one realization and you cannot
observe different potential outcomes
and what you want is you want uh to have
the individual causal effect between
such different outcomes
so one example for this would be a
demand shaping wire price setting
so this is a such an exact causal
what-if scenario when you say
the price was two dollar two dollars but
what would have happened to the demand
if the price would have been three
dollars
and of course you want this forward
looking
so that means yeah you somehow need need
the method that
enables you to do so and machine
learning is one
ingredient to this because it provides
you with the individualization
via its generalization capabilities and
the other ingredient
is deconfounding so for this let's first
look what
what i mean with confounding so in the
diagram
uh on the upper diagram here you could
see uh
three random variables so x would be for
example the price
that you can actually set so you have
you have the possibility
to to change this feature and y would be
your target which is the demand which
you want to influence so that means you
want to
to know the causal effect from x on y
but the issue now is that there are
other variables depicted as set here
which would have an influence both on x
and y so let's say for example the day
of the week
would have an effect on the demand
because more people go
go shopping on weekends but it might
also have an effect on the historical
data that you have from price setting
because
you just reduced the price more often on
the weekend for example
so and you want you want to get rid of
the influence from set on x here to
actually make uh
make a statement about the causal effect
from x and y
so and there are different methods that
you could use so the easiest one is of
course
a randomized control trials so that
means if you can set the price
randomly you would get rid of this
dependency of
saturn x but often you are left with
observational data and you don't uh
you have actually no chance to do so so
then
what what is what is another possibility
is that you use independence weights by
means of propensity scores that are
potentially learned from another machine
learning model
um and so getting so getting by doing so
rid of the of the dependency in your
observational data
um but you could also use some partial
deconfounding so this is sometimes good
enough
and uh smoothing that i mentioned before
can be used to partially impose causal
assumptions so an example is the lower
plot here
which shows you uh day after week a day
of the year
as as feature so you see the seasonality
and
what the smoothing function is here is
basically a sign
so you would not allow for wiggles in
such a smoothing function and you see
lots of
fluctuations of the data also spikes may
be coming from promotions or so
but you would not allow them to be
learned by this feature by just
having a smoothing function of a sign
here so this would be a causal
assumption
uh that this feature or could not affect
more
and this is often uh enough uh to
actually uh
have a bit of causal assumptions in your
method to
to just pimp it to do something like
demand shaping
okay besides the implications on causal
decision making a special kind of
confounding can also affect the
effectiveness
of your demand time series forecasting
itself
and i call this temporal confounding
here in the upper diagram you could see
what i mean so
y again is the demand and you look at
the demand at time t
so let's say today and at time t minus
one let's say yesterday
so what you usually have with
autocorrelations is that you have
a statistical dependency between
yesterday and today
but this is actually at least the bulk
of it is not
a causal effect so this is actually a
spurious correlation coming from the
fact
that you have a confounding with all the
other causal effects on demand
so for example if there's there was a
promotion yesterday there is a good
chance that there is also promotion
today
or if yesterday was summer there is
still summer today
so that means you have a you have a
common cause
for for the two for the two times here
uh which leads to a torque relay
correlation between the two
and this autocorrelation is actually
what is used by most state-of-the-art
time series forecasting methods
so including uh recurrent neural
networks for example so they basically
you
use select target information to do most
of the learning
of course they also include might also
include all the
uh the external features but the
learning of the effects especially uh
of of peaking structures is much harder
if you have the the leg target
information overlaid
so that means if you want to
uh to improve things like explainability
of your model mid and long term
forecasting quality which is not relying
too much on autocorrelation or the
predictability of
rare spiking events it is usually better
to strive for direct learning of the
causal effects
and an easy way to do so is you just not
using
a leg target information in your machine
learning model
so you just drop it from your model so
but then of course you might lose
information because
here you have all kind of hidden
information in that you might not have
in your other features
so to include it again you can just use
a subsequent residual correction
on the finest granularity so that means
on product location or granularity
so this you can do to capture all kind
of missing trends so for example why are
an exponential moving average
over the deviation between between
the predictions and the actual sales you
could see an example
in the lower plot here so this is about
the beginning of the covet crisis this
year
in yellow you could see the sales which
is suddenly rising for this product
group
at some point and you see that the
machine learning method in blue which is
not including lag target information
would not
uh would not predict this but the dashed
line which is after the residual
correction
would uh would just react to it in kind
of an online learning
uh after the first days where it would
see a deviation between the two
so in the end my advice is separate the
autocorrelation this can help a lot
to learn specific effects
so now we come to an interesting little
effect that cannot easily
be treated with a single machine
learning model and this is the direct
influence of one sample on another
so the famous use case in demand
forecasting here is cannibalization and
halo effects so what does this mean
so cannibalization means that the demand
of a product
decreases due to another product for
example in promotion at the same time
you could see this this behavior in the
plot
so here in the upper plot you see a
product that
has a huge sales increase when it comes
to promotion
which is uh which is visualized by the
by the red
periods and there might be another
product uh the lower plot
that has a quite stable sales behavior
but is actually dropping when this other
product goes to promotions because it's
losing sales to this other product it's
get
cannibalized by it so um this
you could actually do with an additional
machine learning
model after your main model so you have
a main model that gets you
the predictions including all other
effects
and then you look at the residuals as
targets
and what you do is you learn individual
parameter for each product pair
kind of a product form
and you only use pairs where you where
one is in promotion so you need kind of
a trigger event
this does not have to be promotion it
can also be another trigger like for
example an out of stock situation
and in the end you also want to have
some feature selection to avoid
overfitting in such a
such a product matrix form and this can
be a quite good method to capture such
effects
so actually employ residuals in such
cases
okay so an uh ever more uh important
aspect of machine learning predictions
is trust especially when it comes to
business critical use cases
so um what you what you want to have in
the end is an individual explainability
this is visualized in in the plot here
so what you could see is is a time
series
where you see the ingredients of a
prediction
so the different factors shown here show
you the different features of such a
model so for example the price events
weather and so on
and you see their behavior over time so
that means you see what
make up the prediction of an individual
product location combination
at each point in time so this shows for
example that
at the first four days in this plot
there was maybe a reduced price which
which drove the demand high and then
it's dropping for example and you could
also see the weekly structure overlaid
in the calendar factor here for example
so a suction individual explainability
uh
helps of course a lot to uh to dig into
root case
root causes for uh for for example um
too high predictions or something like
that so um
one one famous method to get there
is uh generalized additive models
so um and what what is also uh
useful is if you use a multiplicative
model here
so you could see it in the formula what
i mean by that so this is again
uh with the former method of binning um
and such a multiplicative model can come
quite handy because then you directly
get the different features as factors
like in the plot
um and uh usually a multiplicative
approach is also better than an additive
approach for many features because
it helps you to learn the right level of
uncertainty so basically
if the variation is proportional to the
level it's better to
to have a multiplicative model so in the
end what is important to note is that
you should not confuse such an
explainability with the causal structure
so this would actually have you would
have to employ some causal assumptions
this year would only give you
the inner workings of the model so
definitely you should try to build trust
with whitebox ml however you do it
okay so far we have only spoken about
point estimations but in fact
what you really want are predictions of
full probability density functions
so because these are crucial for
subsequent
probabilistic decision making so for
example uh by minimizing a cost function
so let's say you have different risks so
in a retail setting
for optimization this might be a stock
out risks or overstock risks
so and by having a full probability
density function like in the plot here
you could choose a low quantile of the
pdf for ordering
and would have low over stock risks but
hide out of stock risks
and vice versa for high quantiles
so and by by knowing your costs you
could actually use this
to optimize your cost function optimally
so there are different ways to get to
such a pdf so one would be a parametric
approach
where your demand is modeled according
to some
pdf assumption so this uh usually a
negative binomial is a good choice for
for retail cases so this would account
for over dispersion compared to a
possible distribution for example
and you would you would best use
different machine learning models for
both mean and variance
and having that mean and variance and
the causal assumption you would have the
full pdf
an alternative would be an empiric
density estimation
so for example via a quantile regression
so this is of course more flexible but
it's also less robust than a pdf
estimation
so then if you have such a method you of
course also want to check the goodness
of your pdf prediction in the end
so that means you want to evaluate them
and here i just
give a few suggestions how you would do
it so uh
on the left side you see you see a pdf
which you could convert then in
accumulated distribution function
and then you can actually look at the at
the actuals compared to your prediction
which is the dashed vertical line
so you get cdf observations so to say
and by by having such single and cdf
observations you could not tell much
about
the goodness of your pdf estimation but
by looking at
many of them together so for example by
filling them to an histogram you could
come to a conclusion
so such a histogram you would expect to
be flat so that means a uniform
distribution and any deviation from it
would actually hint to some flaws in
your method
so this you could also do in a
quantitative evaluation
by means of of looking at deviations
from the uniform distribution in terms
of for example the earth mover distance
or
coolback libra diversions or something
like that
and you can go even one step further in
the direction of qualitative evaluation
by not looking at the histogram itself
by actually looking at profile plots
according to some other variables so in
the case on the right plot here
you have the the mean prediction on the
x-axis
and you have different quantiles on the
y-axis where you
just compare your cdf observations in a
lower higher perspective
and by doing so you could you could see
first deviations for example in low
quantiles or in high quantiles
but you could also see deviations in
specific areas of the variable you are
looking at the x-axis
so this can be very helpful to really
pinpoint
to some to some flaws in your method
okay and that's it for today so of
course there are many more aspects
to this extensive topic but i hope that
you had some fun with the 10 selected
and
thanks a lot for your attention